SEAN HANNITY IS STANDING BY FROM
WASHINGTON D.C.
>> Sean: GREAT TO SEE YOU,
TUCKER.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE’RE LIVE IN THE SWAMP, THE
SEWER THAT IS WASHINGTON D.C.
TONIGHT I CAN REGARD THE SKY IS
ABSOLUTELY FALLING.
WE’RE ALL DOOMED.
THE END IS NEAR.
THE APOCALYPSE IS EMINENT AND
YOU’RE ALL GOING TO DIE, ALL OF
YOU IN THE NEXT 48 HOURS AND
IT’S ALL PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
FAULT.
OR AT LEAST THAT’S WHAT THE
MEDIA MOB AND THE DEMOCRATIC
EXTREME RADICAL SOCIALIST PARTY
WOULD LIKE YOU TO THINK.
THEY’RE SADLY POLITICIZING AND
WEAPONIZING AN INFECTION
DISEASE.
WHAT IS BASEICALLY THE NEXT
EFFORT TO BLUDGEON PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THEY’RE ALL ROOTING FOR
CORONAVIRUS TO WREAK HAVOC IN
THE UNITED STATES WHY?
TO SCORE CHEAP REPULSIVE
POLITICAL POINTS.
LET’S LOOK AT THIS.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION.
THIS IS WHO WE ARE AS A PEOPLE
TO DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
KEEP EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN AND
FRANKLY EVERYONE WORLDWIDE SAFE
AND HEALTHY.
THIS IS WHO WE ARE AS AMERICANS,
THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
WE PRAY FOR THE SICK, PRAY FOR
THE FAMILIES THAT LOST LOVED
ONES.
THAT’S ALSO WHO WE ARE AS A
PEOPLE.
WE WANT A CURE FOR AIDS, CANCER,
HEART DISEASE AND EVERY OTHER
DISEASE AND AFFLICTION AND WE
HAVE WITH OUR AMERICAN DOCTORS
AND RESEARCHERS, WE HAVE LED THE
ENTIRE WORLD AND WE HAVE
LITERALLY SHARED ALL OF OUR
DISCOVERIES ALL OVER WITH THE
ENTIRE WORLD BECAUSE THAT’S WHO
WE ARE AS A PEOPLE.
BUT TONIGHT, THE FEAR MONGERING
THE OFF THE CHARTS.
NOW WE HAVE SOME ON THE LEFT
LITERALLY WHIPPING THIS COUNTRY
INTO A FRENZY.
SOME PROMOTING EXTREME MEASURES
IMMEDIATELY.
CLOSE SCHOOLS, DAY CARE CENTERS,
BUSINESSES, MASS TRANSIT SYSTEMS
AND THE CANCELLATION OF ANY
LARGE GATHERING.
NOW, IF THINGS DO GET
DRAMATICALLY WORSE, MAY COME TO
THAT.
WE’RE NOWHERE NEAR THAT POINT AS
OF TONIGHT THANKFULLY.
HOWEVER, ACCORDING TO THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA, YOUR LIFE IS
ABOUT TO BE HORRIBLE AND IT’S
ALL DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT.
ONE "NEW YORK TIMES" OPINION
COLUMNIST CALLED THE CORONAVIRUS
THE TRUMP VIRUS WRITING IF
YOU’RE FEELING AWFUL, YOU KNOW
WHO TO BLAME.
DID DONALD TRUMP CREATE THIS IN
A LAP SOMEWHERE?
ANOTHER ARTICLES COMPLAINING
THAT TRUMP HAS A PROBLEM WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS, THREATENS THE
U.S., HIS CREDIBILITY.
FAKE NEWS, CNN’S OFFICIAL
HANNITY STALKER GOT VERY
MELODRAMATIC TWEETING OUT SIPS
THE DAWN OF THE TRUMP ERA,
COUNTLESS EXPERTS HAVE WARNED
THE PRESIDENT’S LACK OF
CREDIBILITY WOULD IMPERIL THE
COUNTRY IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY.
AS THE CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK
WORSENS, THE FEARS ARE COMING
TRUE.
HUMPTY, IT’S QUIVERING WITH FEAR
WITH OLIVER ASSISTANT SOMEBODY.
HE’S A STALKER.
THEY SEEM TO BE HOPING FOR
PANIC, CHAOS, MASS PANIC,
DEVASTATION AND EVEN AN ECONOMIC
CATASTROPHE.
IF IT’S BAD FOR TRUMP, PROBABLY
GOING TO BE GOOD FOR US
POLITICALLY.
IS THAT THE THINK SOMETHING THEY
SEEM TO BE GIDDY ON WALL
STREET’S DECLINE.
WALL STREET IS ALWAYS SKITTISH.
DO THEY CARE ABOUT YOU OR THE
401(k)s?
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE THE LAST
THREE YEARS EXCEPT HATE DONALD
TRUMP EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY 24 HOUR DAY, WEEK,
MONTH?
THAT’S WHAT THEY DO.
ANYWAY, YOU BE THE JUDGE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DONALD TRUMP’S PRE DEDECESSOR
UNDERSTAND WHEN THE NATION FELT
FEAR.
IT WAS A SHOOTING, A DEATH, THEY
HAD EMPATHY.
DONALD TRUMP RENEWSES TO
RECOGNIZE THAT FEAR AND THERE’S
GOING TO BE A GROWING CHASM.
>> WE ALL KNOW THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN THE COURSE OF HIS
SERVICE HAS DISRESPECTED SCIENCE
AND SCIENTISTS, HAS TOLD AN
AWFUL LOT OF UNTRUTHS.
>> JAPAN, THE PRIME MINISTER
THERE ASKED ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
TO SHUT DOWN FOR A MONTH.
THAT’S HOW SERIOUS IT IS THERE.
IMAGINE IF THAT HAPPENED HERE.
>> ALSO A REMINDER TODAY HAS
BEEN A GAME CHANGER.
>> IT’S SHAMEFUL.
PUTS FORTH A PROPOSAL THAT IS
MEAGER ANEMIC.
>> FOUR WORDS.
DESCRIBE THE ADMINISTRATION’S
RESPONSE TO THE CORONAVIRUS,
TOWERING AND DANGEROUS
INCOMPETENCE.
>> Sean: NEVER LET A GOOD
TRAGEDY OR VIRUS GO TO WASTE.
ACCORDING TO THE MOB, I’VE BEEN
TELLING YOU, IF THE DOG BITES,
IF YOU’RE FEELING SAD, IT’S
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S FAULT.
IF PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP CURED
CANCER TOMORROW, THE LEFT WOULD
WANT TO IMPEACH HIM BECAUSE HE
CONSULTED WITH A RUSSIAN
SCIENTIST.
THE SAME PEOPLE WOULDN’T FIND
ONE GOOD WORD TO SAY WHEN IRAN’S
TOP TERRORIST, SOLEIMANI, WAS
TAKEN OUT BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW WE’RE SEEING THE SAY BRAND
OF PETTY POLITICS.
LOOK, IF WE CAN’T GET THE LEFT
TO UNITE AND THE MEDIA TO UNITE
ON KILLING A MASS TERRORIST WHO
KILLS HUNDREDS OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS, IF WE CAN’T WORK
TOGETHER TO KEEP OUR COUNTRY
SAFE FROM ILLNESS, DISEASE AND A
VIRUS, THERE’S NOTHING WE’LL
EVER AGREE ON.
MANY TOP DEMOCRATS ARE SPREADING
THE LIE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP CUT
THE BUDGET FOR THE NIH AND CDC.
HATE TO TELL YOU.
THAT IS A LAW ACCORDING TO THE
AP AND THEIR FACT CHECK.
THE FUNDING HAS INCREASED UNDER
THE PRESIDENT.
WHY LET THE TRUTH GET AWAY?
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
CORONAVIRUS IS DANGEROUS.
THOSE INFECTED ARE CONTAGIOUS
BEFORE THEY SHOW SYMPTOMS.
THEY DON’T KNOW THEY HAVE IT.
THE RAPID SPREAD IS CONCERNING.
THE PRESIDENT, HE HAS BEEN
TAKING IT SERIOUSLY FROM DAY
ONE.
WAY BACK IN JANUARY, WAY BEFORE
THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS, THE WHITE HOUSE
DECLARED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
AND THEN YOU MIGHT RECALL, THE
PRESIDENT BARRED NON-U.S.
CITIZENS WHO RECENTLY VISITED
FROM CHINA FROM ENTERING THE
UNITED STATES.
WOW, THAT’S SOMETHING THAT THE
LEFT AND THE MOB WOULD SAY IS
BIGOTED.
HE’S BEEN ON TOP OF THIS FULLY
ENGAGED FROM DAY ONE.
ALL AMERICANS RETURNING FROM
CHINA WERE SUBJECT TO EXTENSIVE
SCREENINGS AND QUARANTINES.
AGAIN, SOMETHING THE LEFT
WOULDN’T DO.
TODAY ZERO PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA HAVE DIED FROM
THE CORONAVIRUS.
ZERO.
NOW, LET’S PUT THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE.
IN 2017, 61,000 PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY DIED FROM INFLUENZA, THE
FLU.
COMMON FLU.
AROUND 100 PEOPLE DIE EVERY DAY
FROM CAR WRECKS.
OF COURSE IT’S TRAGIC.
BUT DESPITE WHAT YOU HEAR, THE
WORLD IS NOT COMING TO AN END.
IT’S SERIOUS, OF COURSE.
AND AS THE DISEASE CONTINUES TO
SPREAD, THE PRESIDENT HAS
REQUESTED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
HE’S APPOINTED THE VICE
PRESIDENT TO LEAD THE RESPONSE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT IS CALLING ON
ALL AMERICANS TO WORK TOGETHER
TO COMBAT THIS INFECTION
DISEASE.
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA MOB,
THEY’RE HAVING NONE OF THAT.
INSTEAD, THEY’RE MORE INTERESTED
IN LAUNCHING VILE, VICIOUS
PERSONAL ATTACKS FOR CHEAP
POLITICAL POINTS.
SELF-APPOINTED SCIENCE EXPERT.
REMEMBER THAT CONGRESSWOMAN THAT
PREDICTED THE WORLD WAS GOING TO
END IN 12 YEARS?
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ TWEETED
OUT, MIKE PENCE LITERALLY DOES
NOT BELIEVE IN SCIENCE.
IT IS UTTERLY IRRESPONSIBLE TO
PUT HIM IN CHARGE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE AS THE
WORLD SITS ON THE CUSP OF A
PANDEMIC.
THIS DECISION COULD COST LIVES.
THEN SHE HAS BOLSHEVIK BERNIE
THAT WROTE, BY PICKING VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE TO LEAD THE
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC, TRUMP HAS NOT ONLY
CHOSEN SOMEONE UNQUALIFIED BUT
THE PRESIDENT MADE CLEAR HE’S
MORE CONCERNED ACT HIS OWN
POLITICS THAN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE COUNTRY.
BASICALLY SAYING THE PRESIDENT
WANTS YOU TO DIE.
WE CAN ONLY ASSUME THAT ALL OF
THIS AND THE FOLLOWING
STATEMENTS WILL BE PRAISING
COMMUNIST DICTATOR SHIPS AROUND
THE WORLD FOR STOMPING OUT THE
DISEASE FROM THEIR SOCIALIST
HELL HOLES THE ONES THAT KILL
PEOPLE, INNOCENT PEOPLE AND
STEAL THEIR PROPERTY.
SADLY THE POLITICAL VITREAL
CONTINUED ON TV AND WE HAVE THE
VIDEO EVIDENCE.
>> IS THAT THE PERSON THAT YOU
WANT IN CHARGE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK?
SOMEBODY THAT NEEDS TO PREY ON
SOMETHING INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT
THE SCIENCE?
>> WHY IS MIKE PENCE IN CHARGE?
WHAT IS HIS PLAN TO STOP THE
VIRUS?
CABABSTINENCE
ABSTINENCE?
>> WE’RE NOT AWARE OF ANY
EVIDENCE THAT INDICATES MIKE
PENCE CAN DO IT.
>> VICE PRESIDENT PENCE WILL
JOIN US TO RESPOND TO THESE
ATTACKS AND DISCUSS THE DETAILS
HOW THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
AGGRESSIVELY RESPONDING TO
CORONAVIRUS.
IT’S CLEAR.
THE LEFT PSYCHOSIS, THEIR RAGE
IS REACHING NEW DEPTHS OF
DEPRAVITY.
THEY WANT TO RECLAIM THEIR POWER
AND DESTROY PRESIDENT TRUMP,
THEY’RE TREATING A DEADLY VIRUS
LIKE A POLITICAL WEAPON, A TOOL.
IT’S SHAMEFUL BEHAVIOR.
SHOULDN’T SURPRISE US AFTER WE
WATCHED AND WITNESSES THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
IT DOES HURT THE COUNTRY, DOES
NOTHING TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS.
A PERFECT EXAMPLE, THIS COMING
FROM ELIZABETH WARREN.
HER PLAN TO BATTLE CORONAVIRUS
IS TO STOP THE CONSTRUCTION OF
TRUMP’S RACIST BORDER WALL.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT WELL.
LET’S BE HONEST.
THEY DON’T HAVE GOOD INTENTIONS.
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE TO KEEP US
SAFE AND SECURITY AND CREATE
PROSPERITY FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
NOTHING EXCEPT HATE THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY DON’T HAVE GOOD PLANS OR
IDEAS.
THEY DON’T HAVE ANY STRONG
CANDIDATES.
ALL THEY DO IS RAINFALL TOWARDS
THE PRESIDENT.
IT’S A BLOOD THIRSTY LUST FOR